Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and it's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
March 19th.
Dude, I'm in a great mood.
[inaudible] um, I'm to, I don't know why I just sang that song.
I just been watching a bunch of fucking old, you know,
I listened to old country now and then I started listening to old fucking rock
and roll. You know what's his face just died.
The guy used to fucking film chicks that he shit on or something,
whatever his name is. Chuck Berry. Oh, well yeah.
You know, it's part of one of his classics. Abuse in the background.
You getting shitting on? People
have such respect for him too. You know,
it's just one stuff like that gets up once it gets out. Um,
anyway, so I just been a, I'm in a great fucking mood because my fucking show,
I had this a rotator cuff injury and it's just been fucking with me since,
um, October and, uh, I finally found an exercise
works for me. For me. I just feel like for my shoulder,
my shoulder needs a safe place.
[inaudible] lot of crying out
there. Um,
okay.
Alright. So this is, this is the exercise. If you,
if your rotator cuff is fucked up, like mine is, the problem is,
is if you can look what this injury,
it's like he can still pick up the same amount of weight.
You can always pick up depending on the angle,
but then shaking hands or just reaching for a salt shaker,
all of a sudden you like ha this sharp pain.
It's basically what I've learned is it's the muscle.
Like it's when you first go to raise your arm, that first 30 degrees,
that's what the fuck it is.
And then the big boys take over whatever you're doing,
how you lifting your lunch pail up. Maybe you got a giant fucking doughnut,
you want to shove a d a face like I did today. I broke my rules about donuts.
You know, my, uh, my wife, uh, was wanting some donuts,
so I went by, there's a Dunkin donuts out here, right?
So I show up and it's late in the day. It's like fucking two in the afternoon.
So all the donuts are gone. You know, they're still making them,
but they don't have, you know, they don't have that freshness to them.
They got those, you know, the little Munchkins,
they're like the worst flavors left.
It was like blueberry custard and a fuck your mother,
whatever the fuck it was called. And I was like, that's what you got left.
They were like, yeah, let's take, I left.
This is after the people in front of me could not make up their mind,
you know,
can I get, we got a dozen donuts and they lay him down.
Now that's how long it's been since I've seen anybody get does it.
Don't say lay them down.
Back in the day they stood them up and the frosted from one donut gun on another
donut, you know,
and evidently gently with all the iPhones coming out for somebody finally
decided, why don't we make the box a different shape and we'll lay him down.
And I imagine the Steve Jobs of Dunkin donuts went to some sort of comic con of
fat people and he came out in a turtleneck sweater with this fucking new balance
sneakers and he fucking showed off the the box and everybody went, oh my God.
Right there fucking man tits bouncing up and down.
And do you think he gave credit to the poor,
the poor little fucking eight year old in the background who had to put those
things together? Huh?
The blind nine year old girl who fucking designed the box down in fucking east
Albuquerque. You think he gave him any credit cards? He didn't.
Course he didn't. Oh, look who's here. My two angels.
QT number one in QT number two. What's up buddy? Hey Nia,
this is some bad language and if she can't understand it anyways,
what's going on? You want to be on the podcast? Nini? Sure.
We'll grab a mic though.
[inaudible] you checked my nerve and you read them my brain.
Um, yeah, you gotta grab stuff in the bag anyway. So what do we,
what did I do? I know, I know.
Come back. Come back in a minute. Come back in a minute.
I'm in the middle of this story. Oh, all right. All right. Okay.
Bye Cutie. Um,
you know that fucking guy a little time to make the donuts.
That was just an actor. So anyways, so I call up near okay. And I just go, yeah,
they don't have any fucking donuts that their donuts suck there anyways.
And she went, oh my God. She goes, blasphemy. A guy from Boston,
which I'm not. I'm from the Boston area. I'm from the safe suburbs. Alright.
So you can take your goodwill hunting fucking quotes and I, you can talk.
Tell him to somebody else. Cause I grew up in a nice suburb. There was,
it was called the Sachs. We played street hockey.
We roasted marshmallows. All right.
There was no, it's not your fault. There was none of that shit.
Nobody liked apples and I sucked at math. Okay. That's it.
I climbed trees and uh, and I had a paper route. Okay.
So enough with the southeast shit.
Anybody every from Massachusetts is not from South Boston. We didn't steal cars.
Okay. A lot of us are from the suburbs. We slept in bunk beds.
I'm so sick of that fucking movie.
Okay.
Where are you from? You just, you just say, I,
you know from Massachusetts l bought Southie. Did you grow up in Southie?
Did you like apples? Did you say?
How about them apples down at the tasty,
like some fucking stuck-up.
Harvard con is going to mess with anybody ever from fucking swell backwards.
South Boston used to be, now they're all Harvard grads that live down there.
From what I've heard, I have no idea. I don't know what goes on in that city.
Okay. Last time I lived there, they,
they were just starting the big dig and that big ugly green thing was still
there and going from Faneuil hall over to the North End,
you took your life in your hands. You just felt it.
You went underneath the fucking southeast expressway and it was scary,
you know? Anyways, what the fuck am I? So I call her up. I just say, yeah,
I got that done. It's suck. And she goes, oh my God. She goes,
a Boston guy saying, Dunkin donuts sucks. That's blasting me. It's like, Nia,
nobody gives a fuck about that donuts. It's all about the coffee. All right.
I don't drink the coffee. I don't drink coffee.
I don't like it tastes like dirty water. It Burns my tongue.
It stains your teeth. It's just, it's a fucking, it's the Trifecta of, you know,
I guess it helps you take a shit though. I know a lot of people like, you know,
if you could coffee, smoke a CIG, take a good shit, get on with my day.
You know, have a French fucking Corolla.
It's all about the co like their bread and butters. The coffee. Okay.
That's the lead singer.
That's like if Dunkin donuts broke up and the coffee went solo.
All right. That's the George Michael and the donuts, the, the,
whatever the other guy's name was Andrew Ridgeley. Anyway,
so I go, yeah, fuck that place. So, uh, oh. And the people in front of me,
they couldn't make up their goddamn mind. Like, what do you want? Ah, why?
What's in those? Oh,
can we get two with, let's get three of those.
They kept talking to each other is happening, we'll get three of the pink ones.
Um, and I was already having a bad day cause, um,
I keep my truck in storage now cause uh,
we got the little one and it's just easier for my wife to get in and out of the
garage. And I knew if I kept my truck there and show,
always had to squeeze by it and try and get the fucking stroller and all that
shit, you know, it's gonna happen eventually. She's going to be like,
I don't know, what do we need three cars for?
And eventually she's going to make me sell it.
So I did a preemptive strike and I immediately put it in fucking storage before
she could bitch about it. So I had it over the last fucking like five days.
Love. And so I just switch out. All right.
I put Jackie in storage and I take out the old girl. Right.
And I drove her for like five fucking days.
And of course the battery died cause I forgot to unhook the, uh,
the terminals there had to get it jumped out at the comedy store.
Um, and uh, anyway,
so I'm going to return the car today and it's the day before I go on the road.
So we have a rule in my house, in my house, there is a roll.
Um, the basically the day before I go on the road, I bet it's family day.
I hang out, you know, I make breakfast,
I made some fucking meatballs that cook the Goddamn chicken.
I make sure that she's got food in the fridge, you know, I'm a,
so I make sure she's going to be all right. Right. So I go, all right,
I gotta return my truck. She's like, who you p pack? I'm like,
I'm going to be back. So, alright.
So I get in a truck and I do what I always do. I drive down the phone,
I gotta move fucking, you know, I gotta move her car. I become like a valet,
cause I had the shittiest driveway ever it. Right.
So I'm fucking driving up the street and as always, big stupid grin on my face.
It's my favorite thing ever. It's three on the tree. It's so much fun to drive.
And whenever I get a little bit of space out here and I just get the fucking run
through all three gears, that's all I want to do. Every time I do,
I get why I want a second. I get it into third gear.
I always have the window down. Even though I put some ac in there,
I never fucking you. I didn't use it for so long.
I turned it on and all this white shit came out and I breathed it in and
probably took like fucking nine years off my life. Um,
anytime I get it up into third gear and I'm cruising down the street,
I always do the same thing. I always go,
whoa,
every time.
I never did that once in nine years old and my Prius ever. It's just,
it's the greatest sound in the fucking world.
It's the sign of a big fucking American engine.
Make it run through the fucking gears. Loud pipes.
It's the greatest fucking sound ever.
And every time I get through when I go up the street, right?
So I'm having a great time. You know, I'm driving down the street,
I got the am radio one,
I usually listen to Keyshawn Johnson's fucking sports show, but you know,
it's the weekend. So it wasn't on. And any ways I get on to, um,
you know,
I get onto the fucking highway and of course I'm cruising along and right before
we get to, I get to my exit. It's just like this traffic from fucking,
it's like five in the afternoon traffic of a fucking truck.
Jackknifed and it's just, of course my exit.
And I told the people I'd be over there by noon, so I'm starting to feel stress.
I'm like, what the fuck is going on? So I tried to make a fucking, you know,
a bust and move here. Right. Even on from the suburbs, a Massachusetts move,
I'm going to go around all this shit,
act like I'm going to drive by and then I'm going to fucking cut in and I don't
know what the fuck was going on. I couldn't see any, any accidents.
So I'm trying to go from one highway to another, so like, I know what I'll do,
I'll just fucking, rather than go east, like I want to,
I'll just get on the west side, I'll take the highway west, go down one exit,
and then I'll curl back around because I can see in the overpass,
there's no fucking traffic. I don't know where the food was.
Like this offshoot to the on ramp, right? That everyone was going down. Like,
I don't know what the,
like Paul Simon was doing like a free concert of some shit that was the level
of, of, of uh, traffic. So I say,
fuck it. I get out of the traffic, I drive down and get it up to third gay,
right.
I'd fucking go to go west to turn one fucking block, you know,
one exit up and then come back around. And as I fucking go there,
all of a sudden this is all this other traffic going the other direction. And I,
and, and this,
the first time since I started meditating that I had an absolute meltdown.
I literally screamed as loud as I possibly could. Fuck you, la,
every fucking cock sucking mother fucking con fucking every word you could
possibly think, you know, and then I'm fucking just stuck.
And even worst traffic going the other way to go, one fucking exit, you know,
up to come back around.
And all I'm thinking is where the fuck I would be if I just just took the pain
to begin with and just stayed in that traffic jam.
I'd be creeping forward and whatever.
Why didn't I just call the place and say I was going to be a little late? Oh,
you know what bill, cause that would have been the chill thing to do, right?
I didn't. So it turns out I look up, I'm like, what the,
this is like, it's Saturday at noon.
How was he at five o'clock in the afternoon on Friday traffic.
I am like literally beside myself,
just saying every curse I possibly can.
And I look up and there's two little flashers going on and it's tow truck
flashers, right? And I'm like, Oh, here we go. Hey,
this is all rubber necking and on the other side of the road it's fucking going,
you know, like gang busters. Everybody's cruising by. That's where I want to be,
right? And I can't get to it. So I'm like,
you fucking fucking rabbinic in pieces.
What something we changing a tire,
it's going to be a fender bender and I'm losing my shit out there.
If I was a fucking dictator,
I would deliberately have a car on the side of the road changing a tire who'll
never slowed down and looked at it would be eliminated,
would be removed from society, Fred to the fucking pigs,
whatever the hell it is.
Whenever that fest fucking North Korea does to his God damn relatives feeds them
to dogs. That's what I would do. I was actually, I was so fucking mad.
I was like, you know that Fed fucking North Korea.
He's actually making sense to me. You know?
So I get all the way up. I should be careful, man. It makes sense.
Somebody over here a missed me. I'm like, he did do his other, you know,
we set up those two fucking whores over there,
right to take out his fucking stepbrother. Um, so anyways,
I get all the way up to uh, the traffic jam.
Of course it's a little fender bender, there's people standing there,
there's nothing going on, but I'm finally going to get past it.
Finally going to get off the exit,
come around and fucking runs through the gears and fucking go down the other
side.
And what do I see on the other side of the road where it was all nice and clear.
Now there's major traffic can because the dumb con's on the other side of the
highway, I slowing down to look at the shit on my side of the highway.
So now I've got to sit to it fucking twice. And something told me,
don't get off at the first exit bill. Everybody has this idea.
Go to the second exit and you know, and then come back and guess what I did?
I ignored that instinct. Got Off the first one, bom, Bom, Bom,
Bom de fucking dead stop traffic.
And the only way to get back on the highways,
I gotta make this illegal u-turn and I don't give a fuck.
I'm making it and I'm just sitting there cock sucking mother fucking dictate and
fucking cut all their fucking heads off and I'm getting ready to make my illegal
uturn and I just happened to look in my,
your rear view mirror and guess what's two cars behind me? A fucking cop.
Yeah.
I'm like, what are the fucking odds now I gotta go straight. I said fuck this.
So I get in the right lane and I just cruise up and I get out of his sight and I
finally fucking turn around. I got no,
I finally got into a good lane and I came back and then I got back on under
traffic again, looked at the same people looking at the same accident.
There was nothing going on. And then I fucking finally was able to continue on.
And of course they made the call. There was no problem. Nobody gave a shit.
Nobody yelled at me. It was fine. I completely lost my shit and I'm NBA.
I got so fucking mad that when I saw the people on the other side of the road
rubbernecking I gave them the finger and that was all the way to the right
getting off the highway and I gave all of the family it like,
do you realize how immature that is?
I mean I was just like,
have you ever been embarrassed about yourself by yourself?
Like I actually hit that level cause like I stuck my whole fucking arm out the
window giving them the finger. The person behind me could see it be like,
who's this guy giving him the fingertip?
Okay.
You know, I basically said it wasn't one of my best moments. But anyways,
as I mentioned earlier,
um,
I am, one of the great things is I,
somebody showed me this exercise for a rehabbing the rotator cuff and it's
fucking been great. First of all,
what you do is you basically either be or bend over at the waist. No,
you're not going to take it up the ass. Okay.
Before anybody makes that easy joke.
You let your arm hang down and then what you start doing is basically your
finger, your whole, your fingers are pointed at the floor,
your arms hang and straight down and you just make small circles, right?
And counterclockwise or clockwise.
And then you just start to make it bigger and bigger chest to just get to the
point of pain. And then you live there for a minute,
then you back it back down to small circles and then go clockwise.
If you want counterclockwise, you just go vice versa.
You just go the other direction. You do the same thing again.
Whatever that does, it kind of gets some fucking, I don't Lube in there.
I have no idea. I don't know shit about anatomy. Right? Um,
and anyways,
and then what you do is you have your arm straight out,
not straight out. You have it down in an angle. You walk up to a wall.
All right, I have to explain this part perfectly. All right. And by the way,
you're at your own risk on this one.
Um,
you have your arm probably at like a whatever, 15 degree angle.
You're standing right next to the wall, um, sideways. Okay.
Is that perpendicular to the wall? I have no fucking idea. Right? It's like,
just imagine wall was your friend and the two of you went to a,
a general admission concert and you got there early.
Just imagine what the space would be between the two of you,
but you'd be both looking at the same shit, right? It still doesn't make sense.
Perpendicularly the fucking thing. All right, so you reach out,
you touch the wall, all right,
your arms at a 15 degree angle and then you just slowly start walking it up.
And obviously as it gets more straight,
you're going to have to move your body further away from the wall and you just
walk it up with your fingers. So it's basically,
it's the weight of your arm, but your fingers are taken away,
most of the weight and walk it all the fucking way up until it's like you know
the answer in a classroom and you're so excited and your straight up and then
you walk it back down. You do a set of three to five
and I did it. I've been doing it twice a day and my fucking shoulders. Amazing.
And then I sit afterwards. Um, and it feels fucking amazing.
I actually sat down and played a little drums today. It was fucking phenomenal.
And uh, I don't know,
maybe that maybe somebody could explain it a little bit better.
Maybe there's a youtube video of it. I don't know. Um,
so anyways, that's what I've been doing and I feel great. And um,
okay.
The Guy who, uh,
okay
is basically keeping my dog for the rest of her life, so I know she'll be safe,
uh,
was in town and he brought her by and I got to take her on a couple of hikes we
hung out and um, you know, it's sort of like a shared custody thing.
I mean he has a like 95% of the time, but I know she saved,
she looked great and um, it's awesome. I Dunno,
I dunno if it's good or bad for me to keep seeing her,
cause it's always fucking unbelievably sad every time when I give her back.
But as long as I know the next time I'm going to see her,
then I kind of have hope or whatever.
I just keep jokingly say that she went to college and this is like spring break,
you know, she comes back in March or whatever. But, um,
but it's, it, you know, what's great is I know she's okay.
I know she's gonna live out a full life. And you know,
whenever that day comes, when she's coming down to the end of it,
I'm gonna be there. Cause I always, I kind of made a promise, you know,
you know, when you get a dog that's like, you know, that's it.
Like how much you love a dog. It's like, dude, I'm there until the end. And, um,
you know, even though the way it worked out with having a kid and everything,
um, the,
the main point of the whole thing was that she survived and she had a great
life. She's got this, you know,
she's living in a great house now in Arizona and all that type of shit. And, um,
it just means I'll play Arizona more.
And the person who owns it makes frequent treat trips out here,
always drives out. And I think, uh,
he'll always bring it cause he knows that we love our Nia.
Got to see her and everything. She came back over,
the house was hanging out and um, you know,
she met smelt like a, so she was cool, but uh, it really was never a,
Oh my God, I just said a fucking name. I just added her name. Um,
anyways. And uh,
she just basically, you know, it was never about the kid.
It was about everybody else that was going to become and by,
and it was going to be too crazy and the dog was going to get even more
protective. And you know, I went through with the whole trainer.
It was like the dog's going to go to a whole nother level and I just knew
something, something was going to happen with the craziness they having a kid.
So we just, we made the right decision. Um, anyways.
Uh, all right. Where do we go from here? Um,
I'm going to edit that out by the way. That's gonna know you guys.
You said the name you should live is fucking know so many Weirdos out there.
So many Weirdos. So anyways, what have I been up to?
I've been watching a little bit of them match madness as much as I can,
you know, having the Kiddo around, um, I watched Duke,
you know, when their first round, I don't know,
I'm assuming they won the second round or I would have,
I'm assuming that they're in the fucking sweet 16. My Internet sucks right now.
Your Internet is such a fucking, I, I went, I spent all this fucking money.
I was just like, dude, you get me fucking the Internet that Jesus would have.
And they said, all right, it's going to be 9 million bucks. I said,
I'll write that fucking check you, you fucking criminal. And they said, fine.
And I had the best Internet for about six months and then slowly it just start
sucking again.
And what it is is I think they just turn the juice up on your house,
whoever's paying the most for it.
And then the next guy gets bumped back and then he's like, hey,
what the fuck happened? Am I good internet? Well, you know, we upgraded but,
but then he plays, whoever pays more than me.
See I haven't gone back to them in like two years.
And now like I can't even get,
I get internet and like two rooms at my house and the rest of it sucks.
Let's see if I can look this up. March madness.
Okay.
Uh, there we go. Here we go. Here we go. CBS Sports. What's going on? Come on.
This is like, you root for the slowest horse ever. Now come on load.
Oh my God. It worked and it worked. March madness,
2017 live tournament scores. Update. Baba Baba Baba was the fucking bracket.
Kansas is the team we expected. I love Kansas. I love cab. Always.
I don't know why. I've always loved Kansas. I like Duke. UCLA.
It's fucking fun to see them just because there's such a legendary franchise.
Um,
Syracuse exchange plan plans to extend Boeheim I don't see,
I mean how to watch Duke Versus Carolina. What
a the number two blue devils will take on numbers all on the number seven.
Uh Oh, South Carolina, North Carolina.
I when the fuck are they doing that and I gotta wash it all.
All the Duke Games get get taped next year I think I'm going to add to my sports
package and I want to watch as many of the Duke Games and Kansas.
I don't know why.
I've always loved Kansas and Duke, I got into,
cause I got a couple of friends that went there and then I went to a game and
they treated us great. So like we would die. It's over.
I got to call and coach k show. It's all, wait a second.
Did they lose end of the second half?
Why the fucking gay cops beat him? No.
Okay.
88 81 get the fuck outta here. No fucking way.
No fucking way. Duke Score.
I just spelled scores Duke score.
No fucking way. They fucking lost. Ah,
Jesus Christ.
South Carolina scored 65 fucking points in the second half.
They scored 23 in the first half. Duke scored 30 and 51.
Oh Man. I mean, I knew, I knew that they didn't have the team this year,
but shit, I thought they at least get to the sweet 16. Um,
well I hope that Jason Tatum guy doesn't be fucking one and done.
I hope he comes back. Um, and I liked that loop.
Cannard kid, you know Grayson Alley? Yeah. I'm just coming off the bench really.
Well, you'd think, you know, with all that shit I wanted to be hated.
You'd think he'd be a, you'd think he pouted he think he would pout,
but he didn't. He, uh, he was a fucking man about it. All right, well,
congratulations to South Carolina. Jesus Christ.
I know a lot of educators out there loved listening to that in real time.
Me discovering that they fucking lost. Um,
God damn it. All right. Um, the Kansas sets my team, Kansas Jayhawks.
Um, I respect all of them, man. I, I really don't like, you know,
I come from a pro sports town, so, uh,
I don't really have any sort of hatred for anybody. You know what I mean?
I don't even hate the fucking North Carolina. I don't even,
I don't even fucking hate him. I don't hate NC state. I just like,
I love how the tradition of all it, you know, I could sit back, I might just,
I picked the fucking team so I can actually get involved in it, I guess.
Um, so anyways, I'll root for Kansas the rest of the way out.
And I also like seeing UCLA do well. Well, um,
and of course any, any fucking underdog. I was, I was watching Northwestern.
It sucked. Watching them loose. Did they? They lost, uh, they came back.
They were against the, uh, Gonzaga who I'm so old to me,
they're still the new kids in town even though they've been crushing it for
almost fucking two decades at this point. Anyways,
let's get back to the podcast.
Let's get back to maybe something build that you sort of know about.
How about that? So anyways,
I was listening to all this fucking old rock and roll shit, you know, and uh,
of course if you listed all that shit, you,
you're eventually gonna run into buddy Holly. And, uh,
I was in that pig pay pit. The pit debate.
Um,
and I always loved the drums on that and I never knew what the fuck the guy was
doing. I guess he was just playing paradiddles that Guy Jerry Alison. Um,
I just loved the way he plays on that fucking song.
She's playing paradiddles around the kid.
He's got the snares off and I love about wherever the music's going, if it's,
you know, just playing those basic, was it two chords? I don't know.
Shit about guitar, the bright accord, he's up on a higher note or whatever.
He's on the Higher Tom and then he goes to the floor.
Tom then occasionally comes back to the snare.
It's just a fucking beautiful piece of music, you know. And um,
I'm learning this shit right now with my drum. Teach Ya,
um,
about how to finally get my paradiddles and shit and playing singles and doubles
going in and out,
getting them up to speed while being totally relaxed and letting the stick do
the work.
And it's the hardest mother fucking thing in the world because you've,
you already can play it up to a certain speed,
just your own fucked up technique way to just say fuck all of that and drop like
a hundred bpms, you know, and start all over again is a,
is a bitch. But if, uh, if you stick with it, um,
it gets, I am not gonna lie to you.
It gets pretty fucking exciting where all of a sudden it's just like, wow,
I don't even feel like I'm, I'm exerting any effort whatsoever.
And I'm like three quarters up to what used to be my full speed.
Um, I dunno. It's exciting shit. So by the way, you know,
now that I've got the Kiddo, my lovely daughter, um,
who every time I think I can't,
I'm not gonna like you don't think the loves can go any further.
They develop more and more of their personality comes out. You're like,
oh my God, she does that. And then it just goes to a whole level.
Like now she's smiling like you can't believe. Um,
and the other day I was sitting there, I was with her and a diapers clean.
She's got a full belly. I'm holding her,
I'm doing all this shit that usually stops her from crying and she's just being
cranky and crying. I was just like, what the fuck could this possibly be?
And that's my favorite part about being a parent right now is trying to figure
out the, the riddle, like what's going on with her.
And you know what I figured out for all you guys with newborns, you know,
that it's starting to develop out there. You know what I figured out?
I was like, she's fucking bored. I'm doing the same shit.
And this shit was interesting for about a week to 10 days and now she's over it
because she's hit a new level of consciousness, you know,
she could see a little bit better, whatever, hear a little bit better.
She started understand all those on my feet, you know, she needs something else.
So, um, you know, we do like this tummy time thing,
trying to get her to pick up her head and learn how to crawl and stuff.
So I brought her over to the little pad thing and it's this little thing that's
got like, you know, all these little, you know,
rattles and shit hanging down from it.
And I just turned her over onto her back and I had a look at those things and
she just looked up and was completely enamored with them.
And like that's the new thing. Now I put it on a back when she looks at him,
she smiles and I'm like, they're her friends.
And this is the greatest thing ever.
Because up until now I've had to carry around like a Kettlebell everywhere I
went and was, you know, messing with my shoulder and shit. But you know,
you love your kids, see like, fuck the shoulder, the shoulder comes, I distant,
you know, 20th in this race, you know, for the first 19 spots and my daughter,
right? So, um,
now what's great is I can just bring that tummy time thing into where I'm
watching sports. I put her on her back,
she's looking at the fucking her friends hanging and I can sit on the couch and
keep that thing moving with my bass drum foot. Right as I'm watching,
as I'm watching the games, it's like the greatest thing ever.
I watched like a whole first half of 'em,
Northwestern Gonzaga. I just sitting there and doing that movement.
It's the greatest thing ever.
So if you've got a kid that's crying out there and the diapers clean and
they've, they've done full and all that, maybe they're just bored.
Try something new, some new stimulus. Um, oh, I was so sick. Right.
It's such a luxury to not have to be holding our all every five seconds,
you know what I mean?
Cause I like these little fucking kettlebells and they are hot.
They're hot as hell. They like this hot water bottle, you know,
they getting all hot. You're getting all fuck. It's just awful. It's like,
you see, it's like you're stuck in a crowded elevator.
Uh, yeah. I feel like I'm going through menopause. It's like,
do the fucking hot flashes here. Hot flashes. Um, anyways,
so let's do a, let's do a little bit of a,
let me read some of the advertising air. Everybody, the a the advertiser.
What am I doing? I just, I just opened the maps. Why would I do that? All right.
Oh, dirty lemon. You know, I finally tried some of this stuff.
It takes a second. It kind of tastes like shit a little bit with a Lew,
the lemon, cause it's got the fucking shock all in there. But once you drink it,
um, you know, it's all right. But it also says on the side of the bottle,
this has not been tested or approved by the food and Drug Administration.
So I was kind of like,
what the fuck am I putting in my body to be honest with you? But you know,
here's their advertising. Just being honest, dirty lemon, everybody.
Um, evidently I've been seeing these stripe dirty lemon bottles everywhere.
I haven't. And now I have them in my fridge. I do.
Dirty lemon is a functional beverage brand with products with optimize various
areas of your life, like vitamin water,
but without the added colors slash sugar.
Plus the products actually work well. Maybe that's why it tastes like shit.
They took the sugar out of it. Uh, there are three types now. Sleep, detox,
skin plus hair. Jesus, I need the last one like a fucking,
I needed this 10 years ago and each one contains the juice of one lemon.
No sugar is blended with functional ingredients that actually work there.
Sleep drink for example, includes magnesium, rose water,
camel meal and passion flower, all which help? No wonder it tastes like shit.
I'm drinking flowers here,
which helps you fall asleep fast and stay asleep through the night.
Evidently I drank one the other night before bed and had crazy dreams.
Talk about the dreams to these guys at weird. I didn't drink this shit.
I want to drink so that makes me have crazy dreams.
You know that I'm going to have a crazy fucking dream.
And the detox is secretly is a secretly great hangover. Cure.
Drink a bottle and the debated charcoal absorbs toxins in your body.
Great. After a long night out. All right. Male Shit. I could have used that.
The, I should have drank that today.
Okay.
You know, I know I said I was going to stop boozing, but I got a problem.
So I drank the whole night, but I cut the BU's way down. Whey the fuck down.
You know what I mean? Like when you phase in somebody out of your life,
but they're kind of a cycle you get, you can't do it abruptly.
You gotta kind of a sort of waltzed them over to somebody else. All right,
call to action. Uh,
the best part about dirty lemon is that there's only one way to order is via
text message. You'll never find it in stores to or to go to dirty lemon.com.
Register your mobile number,
then send them a text message Saeilo to a real human and a few texts.
After a few texts, that six pack is sent to your door in one to two days.
Once you buy via texts, you'll never want to go back. Well,
if then that in store stores, how the fuck am I seeing them everywhere?
You know Jesus,
when you text them mentioned you've heard about them on my podcast,
and they'll throw in an extra case of the sleep drink for free with your first
order. 12 bottles for the price is six. For more info,
checkout dirty lemon.com dirty l e m o n.com and text them.
Bill Barr sent you to claim your special offer.
Okay.
All right. Oh Shit. Bodo Dope, dope. My young days, me on Ds,
I'm wearing 'em right. Fucking now do, do to to me on these me undies.
I added donut. Now I'm a cow. My fucking man.
Tits hang lower than my balls.
I got saggy thighs and that's not all bought.
My balls are safe and they're nice in company with this fucking poker dot print
here. I got black and white Polka dot print right now. Now this is, you know,
you know what it reminded me of?
It reminded me it's one of the jerseys that when you win a stage in the Tour de
France, total France Tour de France,
Jersey color meaning here we go. Let's see.
What does the Polka does that the fast one?
Yeah.
What does the yellow, the yellow is, you're the leader. Yeah.
Oh, for Christ
sake. What are the different jerseys mean? What do they mean?
This is still part of the advertising. Just fucking hang in there. All right.
The Different Tour de France jerseys. You know what?
Thanks for nothing. You cons. What does this clickbait. Oh,
it's the Christian Science Monitor.
I got to learn about Jesus to find out what the Mer Tour de France jerseys.
It's still the same page.
Cycling Jersey. Okay. All right.
Where's the polka.one? Oh, it's red polka dot.
What does that one mean?
Red Polka Dot Jersey means all you went up the mountain.
You're the fastest motherfucker on the mountain. All right, well, you know,
there you go. Well, that's what that means. Anyways.
Elevate your underwear game to the next level with me on ds.
You've perfected your wardrobe, but what about this stuff?
Not everybody gets to see if you'd been settling for store bought underwear,
five packs. I have something that will change your life for the better.
[inaudible] what's the first thing you put on? The last thing you take off?
Don't say your socks. You fucking Weirdo. It's your underwear. Make the most,
make your most important piece of clothing the best it can be with me undies.
What is Mandy's? Oh, just seriously soft.
Feel good undies delivered right to your door.
Do you think you could have a fucking fight to the death naked?
Do you think you would like,
I would be so self conscious that my junk was hanging out.
Like if you find your underwear you'd be fine cause you feel like it,
that it's covered up. Psychologically it's covered up. You know what I mean?
But I mean despite the fact that somebody needs you in the balls,
EBV had on fucking, you know, Jay Leno, fucking dad jeans,
it's still going to hurt. Just pretty much just the same. But have you have,
you have fucking underwear on. It's still gonna hurt.
But for such psychologically, if you fought naked, I don't think he could do it.
You know what I mean? It takes a special someone to just be like, yeah,
you know, you know what it is.
It's those guys that get hookers that already let them kick them in the balls.
You ever seen those guys? If you ever seen those fucking porno videos? I have.
They just booted right in the balls.
It's one of the funniest things you're ever gonna Watch.
Um, I dunno, I vote for that funniest porn out there.
Is that a subset of comedy? Funniest Porn? I would say that.
And then those ones where the girls like make the choking sound on the Dick.
You know, if the guy's banging her and he's just cause she's going, Oh la, la,
la, la, like that. There's no way.
There's no way to not just burst out laughing. I mean it's like three stooges.
Like shrimp could make a funny noise than that. Anyways,
if you've been settling for store underway, what the fuck am I talking?
What me and what is me undies? You might ask, oh, just seriously soft.
Feel good undies delivered right to your front door. Um, hey,
I didn't know if the next to you is who lives next door to you?
Is it shooting Porn Nadia? No,
because you'll be laying there in the afternoon and all of a sudden you just
here, you know from the other side of your driveway,
Miyagi's are designed in La and made from sustainably sourced micro modal,
modal fabric, three times softer than cotton.
Biondi softer than soft luxury undies comes in an ever changing selection of
classic colors, bold shapes. I mean there's only one way.
I mean people don't really shape so many different ways and adventurous
patterns.
So you can tailor your undies to your own personal style and guess what?
You can save time and money each month with a monthly subscription. As always.
How much do you shit yourself that you got to get underwear every month.
And if you're not ready for a subscription, that's okay, you can still save.
That's because Manny's is offering 20% off your first pair.
Just use our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash burn and get 20% off your first pair.
So go ahead revamp your underwear drawer. You deserve it. The once again.
That's me. undies.com/burn me undies.com/berg. All right,
well I'm here. We've got left here. All right, we got three left.
I'll read one more and then I'll read two later. All right. Blue Apron,
everybody. Blue Apron. It's important. I've,
I've never needed these people more than I do right now.
After eating a fucking donuts. Important to know where your food comes from.
Okay.
For less than $10 per person, per meal,
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes along with pre-portioned ingredients to
make delicious home cooked meals.
Choose from a variety of new recipes each week,
or let blue aprons culinary team surprise you. Oh, is that a radish?
Recipes are not repeated within a year, so you'll never get bored.
Upcoming meals include all cheese. You can be eating like a dictator's wife.
You know, they do. They never put on the same pair of shoes. Um,
do you think that fat guy in North Korea lets his fucking girlfriend kicked him
in his balls?
Oh,
and then afterwards he walks up to, all right, and that's what they do.
And then they feed their uncle to the dogs and that my friends is North Korea.
Spicy shrimp and Korean rice cakes with cabbage and
furry cocky pork chops and garlic Piccata.
Maybe that's what he calls his Dick Furry, cocky.
That's his nickname for his dick with scallion rice and spinach mushroom and
chipolte laid pepper and enchiladas with lime sour cream.
Customize your recipes each week based on your preferences.
Blue Apron has several delivery options so you can choose what fits your needs
and there is no weekly commitments that you get the deliveries only you want.
This is the deal.
Check out this week's menu and get the first three meals for free.
D was free
shipping by going to blue apron.com/burr you will love how good it feels and
tastes to create incredible home cooked meals with blue apron, so don't wait.
That's blue apron.com/burb blue apron.
A better way to cook and a way to stay in shape or get in shape. All right,
this is a quick one. Simply safe. Earlier this month,
consumer electronic at the consumer electronics show.
It wrapped up in ces is the incredible, is this incredible trade show,
what all the big tech companies unveiled their newest innovations.
It's like seeing the future in front of your eyes.
Our sponsors simply safe home security was there and they had one of the most
talked about products that the show did. You hear about them?
We face the new simply safe security camera.
The camera connects to the sensors in your alarm system.
So if an intruder tries to break in,
the camera will automatically start recording as pretty dope. Uh,
busted night du Du, Du, Du, Du,
du Du du can still lose. Um, then not only will simply save, call the police,
but you'll actually have, you'll actually have, you'll have actual evidence.
Sorry. So when the police arrived, you can say, here's the Guy
Gary is right there. Holy Shit. Is that OJ Simpson? It's truly incredible.
Plus with simply safe, you can check in at home anytime, anywhere.
Just live stream HD footage directly to your smartphone.
Imagine if it was your fucking neighbor and you're in like the Cayman Islands
and it fucking goes to your phone and you had the guy's number and you could
fucking call them up after you called the cops. He called him up, be like, hey,
a rental orange off James Simpson. Listen, Nah, Nah, dude, Nah, no, no.
We're all good. We're all good. You sound weird, dude. Are you okay?
You got a weird sound of your voice? Yeah, I'm still in the Cayman Islands.
Guess what buddy? Guess what I got simply safe.
What is that?
It's the security system that just filmed your fucking psycho ass breaking into
my apartment. The cops are pulling up right now, OJ.
Huh? What do you got to say about that? All right. Hey,
if you want to see for yourself with simply saves,
brilliant technology can do for your home,
go to simply say bird.com you'll even get a special 10% discount that simply
safe burr.com simply spelled s I, m p l, I,
safe.com for 10% discount off your home security system. Simply safe,
burr.com I might as well read the last one and it's nice and quick.
It's stamps.com everybody. Do you still go to the post office?
Oh my God, that's so 2012 you know something?
I use stamps.com anytime I'm, you know, anytime I'm selling posters and I need,
you know, whore myself out at the end of the fucking show,
I want to shake some sweaty hands, you know,
look at some gray red wine teeth. That's what I do when I go out there. Listen,
if I can figure it out. So can you, so if stamps can save time,
save you time and money, which you can use to grow your business.
I can mail a letter,
any package using just my computer and my brand and the mailman comes and picks
it up and it is a man actually, actually isn't. It's a woman.
The male woman comes and picks it up. Unlike the post office,
stamps.com never closes.
You can print postage for letters or packages at your convenience, 24, seven,
seven days a fucking week. It's convenient. It's easy, it's reliable,
it's flexible. You know,
like some chick that'll bang you without a relationship. Convenient, easy,
reliable and flexible.
No need to lease an expensive postage meter right now.
You can enjoy the stamps service with the CF fucking itch right below your ear,
right behind your job phone and it makes you want to cough.
Is that to use station tube? Uh, no. Need to lease an expensive postage meter
right now. You can enjoy, you can enjoy stamps,
stock stamps service with a special offer that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without a longterm commitment.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburthatstampsdotcomenterburststamps.com
never go to the post office again. And guess what,
that's the end of you guys listening to me.
Read out loud what least advertising.
Was there anything else I wanted to talk about before I fucking got into the
Goddamn, um, oh yeah, you know something.
I'm going to be in San Jose if anybody knows that good a rehearsal space out
there that has some good sounding drums and I can maybe go over there for a day
or something like that. Cause I don't get to, you know,
I'm always on the practice pads here and I miss playing drums and I'm learning
all this cool shit. And you know the deal, man,
I'd love to get those Fucking v drums.
It'd be nice if they hooked me up with a free one and I could talk to my
listeners about how awesome they were. Wink, wink, nudge, nudge,
gimme the fucking drums. Um, but you know, playing on a real kid,
that's the real deal. You know, I love those electronic kits,
but at the end of the day, they make you sound fucking amazing. You're like,
am I the next John Bonam? I think I am. And then you get behind a real kid.
You're like, oh, wait a minute. I suck. All right.
Donut shop while in San Jose. Hey Bill,
I know you've been in San Jose.
I know you'd be here coming up and I think I know of a spot that's totally your
style. It's called Stan's donuts.
I know you're cutting the carbs and shit,
but God damn is it worth the extra elliptical time.
Just an old school doughnut shop that's been around for decades and it hasn't
changed a bit. None of that crazy soy-based gluten-free,
pomegranate fritter with cruelty free bacon bullshit.
Just the classics chocolate.
Maybe an old fashioned or jelly filled you fucking asshole.
I'm trying to lose weight. Don't tell me about this place,
but holy shit.
The only one you need from Stan's is the plain glaze donut.
I'm going to be there with Dean del Ray. Oh, he's off sugar. So he won't do it.
They will give you a glaze donuts so, so fresh.
It might burn your mouth if you aren't careful and you can see them pulling them
out of their fryer. Just find the counter. Can't be that dude.
My mom used to take me here before school when I was really little and I came
back for the first time in like 15 years the other day and it's even better than
I remembered. Well, you got a little child sense memory going on there.
Oh my God. Do. Why are you doing this to me?
Immediately thought of you and that you'd like the old school feel of the place.
It's like five minutes from the San Jose Improv. Make it happen. Do it for Stan.
Oh God. Yeah.
Well I can tell you that's definitely happening. Well,
you know what I'm going to do? I'm going to do a tour of of San Jose,
one of my city tours. We're definitely, I'm going to fucking go there.
I'm going to end there eating a fucking donut. Well, maybe I'll start there.
Just hating myself. All right,
Redskins, Redskins.
I'm sitting here listening to your podcast and the fast money past Monday,
and I'm thinking about the Redskins. Keep the name change.
The mascot changed the mascot to a potato.
That's fucking hilarious. But that's not intimidating. You know what I mean?
But Redskins then those, of course the nickname would be the hash browns.
But you know what? You know Hash browns are delicious.
That's fucking hilarious.
I want you know something that's actually fucking brilliant.
So you still call them the Redskins. You change the mass potato, the math,
the mascot, the mashed potatoes, the mascot to a fucking potato.
You know something that's one of the most brilliant fucking ideas I think that's
ever been fucking sent in.
God knows I've never said anything better than that. That's fucking brilliant.
Change it to a fucking potato.
But then what do you have on the side of your helmet then? You know what you do?
You just go back to the old logo with the r on the side
in the feather hanging off is the red skin. Like you peel the potato.
You know the thing when people like they peel and they go all the way around in
a circle, it could be like that
great idea. Then right there. That's a funny motherfucker.
I hope you are very successful in life. Thank you for the uh,
that's fucking right. I didn't ever think of that. And I'm,
I'm slipping as a comedian. All right. The Great Barrier Reef.
By the way,
did you hear Netflix is going to switch from the stars from five stars to thumbs
up, thumbs down. I don't know. Why would you do that?
You know, cause I give, you know, if it's just thumbs up, thumbs down.
It's just such a wide peanut butter and jelly sandwich.
Thumbs up gourmet meal on the French Riviera watching the fucking from a yacht
watching the fucking, the end of a Formula One race in Monaco.
Thumbs up the Godfather. Thumbs up,
meatballs, thumbs up.
Do you know what I mean?
Drinking orange juice after brushing your teeth. Thumbs down.
Adolf Hitler. Thumbs down.
I guess cause they get the fucking ratings. It doesn't matter.
But I mean I like it. I like, it lets me know, you know,
like, okay, people like this. How much do they like this?
I Dunno. Three stooges, thumbs up, Schindler's list, thumbs up.
I mean it's just a what, what, what does anything mean? Anything after that?
All right, great barrier reef. Hey Billy boy.
Huge fan of the show. Thank you.
Remember you were talking about the Great Barrier Reef a couple of weeks or
months ago. Not really. Not really sure anymore. Too Much Wiedemann anyway,
I saw this on the front page of the New York Times and thought you would enjoy
shitting on Australia some more. I don't like shitting on Australia.
I was just shitting on that guy.
It basically says that huge sections of the Great Barrier Reef that stretch
across hundreds of mile.
We're recently found dead and they were killed by over heated salt water.
I know this is coming from a liberal paper,
but I think it's pretty clear evidence. There is six significant global warming.
Anyway, you fat, a bola written piece of shit.
Love the podcasts and keep on keeping on. Um, yeah,
I gotta be honest with you. I don't want,
I don't read up on a lot of the environmental stuff. Uh,
cause it's too fucking depressing. I love animals, man.
I love the earth man.
I don't want to see fucking sea life dying and all that shit.
Um, I dunno. I Dunno what this is just too many of us.
It's just like I think a plague is coming or,
um, I actually think that the robots,
uh,
will be in control of the upper one percenters and they will gradually take all
of us out. And then what it will be,
will each one of those Illuminati guys will have their own robot
with all the answers. It's every, it's a fucking,
it can play guitar like Jimi Hendrix.
It can design the most beautiful architecture.
It's the greatest farmer. They just, whatever you need it to fucking do,
we can do so you'll never go hungry. You'll always be entertained.
And on top of that, it'll be the best look and chick you've ever seen in life.
And you can fuck his brains out. I mean right there.
If that's not going to be the extinction of all the regular people like,
like myself. I think that that's what's going to happen. And then, um,
the earth will gradually cool, but all of our deaths,
the Great Barrier Reef will come back and I'm,
the upper 1% will have what? They always wanted complete control. Um,
but I actually think they'll get bored after awhile. You know,
there's nobody to oppress. There's nobody looked down on, you know,
that's actually a fascinating fucking movie.
Would it be like there's just no more challenge.
Right. And those robots know how to like, you know,
they can like grow an ear in a petri dish.
Eventually we'll be able to grow all vitals, you know what I mean?
And then you can just live forever.
Uh, what would you do?
Okay.
What would you do? This is reason why you die. You just run out of shit.
What the fuck would you do? I would just keep learning shit.
Okay.
It's like all right. For the next 80,
like every 80 years you just picked be in something. Alright.
This 80 years I'm going to be a gearhead.
I'm going to learn how to take a whole fucking car apart. Put it back together,
make it fast, fast and loud. I'll just learn how to do that shit.
I'll have the robot right here. It knows everything.
It'll fucking teach me how to do it. And then once I get it down, you know,
and I do that for awhile. You know?
Fuck it. Learn every instrument. Learn every language.
You're eventually just going to run out of shit to do.
You'd just be looking at your robot. Just going like, dude,
I know this is fucking nuts. I know we've been together now, sweetheart,
for fucking 800 years, but could you do me a favor?
Do you want me to kick you in the balls? Not know, sweetheart. I don't,
it'd be funny if they, even though it looked totally look real,
it totally felt like a real person, but they can never perfect the voice.
So it's still fucking talk like that.
You are the best I've ever had. Just like,
bitch, stop talking. You're killing it for me. Um,
you'd have to just say to the fucking thing, look, 800 years.
Okay. I'm coming up on 800 years. All right.
I've lived more years than Hank Aaron hit home runs.
Could you do me a favor on my 800th birthday?
I know what I want. Okay.
Could you just choke me to death? Please
don't not compute. You know, and it, you just,
they won't kill you and then you're fucking,
your punishment is that you live forever. You know,
you kind of like a vampire at that point,
cause you can kind of seduce any woman you want because they're all going to be,
you know, you're just going to get, but you know what? I bet after awhile,
if you live long enough, you just start banging. You'd have,
you'd make like ugly chick robots and he just banged them cause you was so sick
of bang intense. I mean, it's a fucking, it's a hell of a, God damn it.
I don't think human beings can survive in that. Just,
you just think of all the shit that that's gonna happen.
Alright, female comedians. What the fuck is this?
I didn't know this was coming up. All right. Hey Baby Daddy,
Billy boy emailing from Dublin,
a big fan of the podcast to stand up.
I've been watching a lot of stand up specials over the last month.
Recently I'm making a concentrated effort to watch female comedians because all
the Comedians I'm a fan of are men.
Unfortunately I've struggled to find many who meet the mark.
I just watched so-and-so's Netflix special, which was hilarious. Okay,
then I'm going to say the name Kathleen Madigan. Yes.
She's the fucking real deal and she's a total hot shit. I love her.
She's been fucking crushing it since, since I started.
Um, English comedian Joe Brand was also excellent, although I dunno if she's,
she's still active beyond all the others I've seen.
All the other had been shit in my opinion. Uh,
my issue with this disparities that I don't think men are funnier than women in
general. The women in my life, like my girlfriend,
my sister and friends are just as funny as my guy friends. In your experience,
which you find male comedians funny or like myself is,
so why do you believe this is the case?
Could it be the fact that the industry is so male heavy or women comedians
trying too hard to emulate their male counterparts?
These are all questions I can't answer. I don't fucking,
I don't know what the deal is. Again, it's all your opinion. Um,
maybe I'm just an ignorant prick,
but I feel like there's a female perspective in comedy that would speak to me
that isn't met by the better known female comedians. Either way.
Thanks for the laughs.
Congrats to you in the lovely Nia on the little baby bird. Go Fuck Yourself.
Um, I dunno dude. It's like, you know, you know what it is.
I just think it's like bands. You,
you're into a certain style of music and the other shit doesn't speak to you.
CDOT. You don't go to that. But every once in a while there's a band, you know?
Oh fuck. I didn't think I liked country music. I like this country music.
I just think, uh, I dunno what the deal is.
I don't know why there's so much of that fucking talk. My Shit is this okay.
If you're fucking funny, you're funny. If you're not funny,
you're not funny. Okay? And it's not the crowds fault. It's not this,
it's not the fucking Martians. It's your not funny.
And one of the things I found with people, male and female, who aren't funny,
is they fucking got every God damn excuse in the book. And I just want to say,
hey,
just go on stage and fucking kill and all your problems will be solved.
Go on stage and fucking kill. That's what it was. You know,
that's what it's always been. If you do that,
all of these fucking issues that everybody all is this over here,
there's that over here, there's a fucking liberal bias. There's all of this.
It's all fucking bullshit. If you go on stage and you fucking kill,
you're going to get work. That's it. That's it. So I don't, I dunno,
whatever. I'm, I'm so fucking sick of all, all of that. Uh, you know,
our women funny I blah, Blah Blah. And so just lump everybody into a group.
I is more just asked me, do you,
do you think Kathleen Madigan's funny just asked me that in that email.
I think she's fucking hilarious. I love her delivery and you know,
I love about her. She can just stand there and be funny.
I got to jump around screaming, yell, Acts Shit out.
She can just stand there and fucking murder for an hour.
And you know what's great too is you meet her and she's totally down to earth
and she's fucking awesome. So there you go.
That's the positive way of me getting out of that type of shit cause I'm not
walking into that like,
why the fuck do you think I would answer any of that shit? You know what I mean?
Look what business are you in? Okay.
Why don't you shit on some people in your fucking your fucking arena.
I don't want to do that. That's cannibalistic. Um,
oh my God. I mean there's, there's so many fun. I do.
I kind of like name funny female comics for you.
Is that what I got to fucking do now? I got to do your fucking homework.
All right. Feeling in love with my best. Uh, with my lesbian best friend.
Hey Billy Dad bought. Oh Jesus, you're so fucking right.
I'm a huge fan of all your shit.
Why are you calling it show? I'm an artist.
I loved your new special. I need some advice.
I'm a young guy and I haven't even tried to get into a relationship in a few
years because my last one turned into a fucking nightmare. Anyways,
over the past year,
I've been hanging out with this lesbian and we've grown close. Uh,
Jesus doing this is gonna. This is the ultimate.
This is the ultimate just,
yeah,
cold case file. Dude's you chasing the chase and leads that aren't even there.
She's amazing and my best friend.
The problem is I find myself growing more and more attracted toward by the day.
We've talked about having a threesome.
Woo.
Which makes me think she might want to fuck me,
but doesn't want to admit it to herself. Oh, strike everything that I just said.
Dude, you, you have fucking walked into paradise. I am happy for you,
my friend. God bless you. God fucking bless you.
I hope this fucking turns out the way I think it's going to.
I'm so you just made the rest of my day that someone's in this situation right
now.
Lately she's been trying to get me a girlfriend, probably.
So there's sexual tension can be redirected. What the fuck do I do, Bill?
Please help me and go fuck yourself. But what do I do, dude,
I've never been in this situation. I'm living vicariously through you.
What do you do? Don't fuck it up.
Yeah,
Dude. Okay. Wait a minute.
Who's been in this situation and don't fucking lie to me.
Sending what this guy can do so he doesn't fuck this up. Oh Dude,
God fucking bless you. Uh, what do you do?
Um, oh Jesus. What? Okay. What the fuck would I do?
I Dunno, man. I, I, you know what I would do? I'd go out drinking with her,
right? And uh, I would fucking say, all right, just pick somebody out.
Who Do you like? You go up, you strike a conversation. You know what I mean?
Maybe she strikes up the conversation so the fucking, the, the,
the other lady keeps it to Defensive Shield down, you know? Okay,
this is what you do. Do you get into great fucking shape? Okay?
You got to help out your lesbian girlfriend. Okay?
You get yourself a new fucking wardrobe.
You gotta look right when you're going out.
You put on a pair of fucking me on this. Okay?
You eat blue apron for a god damn month. You shed some fucking pounds.
You put on some B on these, you dress fucking right. Okay.
Give you a lesbian friend, something to work with other. Any Lesbians?
Listen to this fucking podcast. How does this go down?
Okay.
Hey, yeah.
Fuck. Maybe she knows. Hang on a sec. Let me hit pause.
You know what I realized? You know,
I realize she's going to come in here holding my daughter and we,
we can't talk about this shit when she's here. All right,
well I'm going gonna have to put this, this one I can't do okay. And I went to,
Oh fuck the podcast. She's never going to be on again.
Now my daughter's developing, eventually she'll be playing with toys.
She can sneak in here and, and she can, she can answer some goddamn questions.
All right. There you go. Um, or
I don't know how to do it anyways to just, I don't know what to tell you, dude.
I'm so fucking excited. I can't even think straight right now. God bless you.
I hope this fucking works out, man. And I, I want,
I want to hear the fucking story. Um, okay lady.
She's been trying to get me a girlfriend probably.
So this sexual tension can be redirected. Yeah. Uh, you know,
so basically every once in a while she doesn't mind banging a guy.
As long as there's a, you know, you know what it's like.
It's like you're going out to a restaurant, right?
She's going to order one thing.
You're going to wear the other thing when she's going to take a couple of
fucking, you know, a couple of spoonfuls off of your plate.
That's what's going to happen here. Oh my God, this is fucking tremendous.
Fucking tremendous. God bless you, dude. I have no advice.
I've never been in that situation. That's tremendous. All right,
good luck to you. All right, everybody go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you on Thursday and I'll check in on you on Thursday and thank you
to everybody. My shows is sold out in San Jose.
I'm doing two Monday to Tuesday to Wednesday.
I'm working with a the Great Dean del Ray.
We're going to fucking kill it when we're up there. Um,
and also I need to hype the show. I have coming up, I'm doing a fucking a,
we'll send the link out, um,
on a march. Dah, Dah, Dah. Where the Fuck Megan,
I'm doing this Ms. Benefit in there honoring Richard Pryor and it's on March
25th, 7:00 PM out here in Los Angeles. Uh,
I'll put up the link for tickets and all that. I believe we just tweeted it out.
Um, I'm going to be co-hosting with Craig gas.
It's going to be all these amazing there.
It's going to be a great night for a great cause. A hope.
You guys can make it down. That's a Saturday night. Come on, come on down.
There's a fucking Taco truck down. There's gonna be a great time. All right,
that's it. Go fuck yourselves. I'll check in on you on Thursday.